bap bap bap it's funny to me to think
about all the guys that cheated and are
now stuck with the person they cheated
with and their lives are worse now oh
yeah you wanted to date that cute surfer
chick that's super outdoorsy surfer
chick she's not so fun in a studio
apartment all day was way cuter when she
was at the beach surfing not so fun now
is it not so cute you want to date that
cute little emo drummer chick sharing a
studio apartment with a drummer chick
not so fun and Quarantine is it hey I
bet you wish you were still with the
who has acreage hmm oh you wanted
to leave me for that girl who has three
roommates who enjoy that enjoy that
right about now oh I'm over here with a
garage and a pool
hmm I'm a quarantine catch I'll tell you
that right now I know I know my worth
right now
two months ago I was obnoxious now I'm a
dream girl quality dream girl whoo I'm
cracking up but the most afraid about
that